et maintenant
voici quinze ans
quel un bon soir vous donner c'est tout
le monde oui je connais à peu près tout
le monde
kenza vous passez votre vie sur ce
plateau donc désormais vous êtes une
habituée de la maison 1
c'est vrai vous êtes venus ici à
quelques semaines face à romain goupil
au sujet de la guerre d'irak puisque
votre vrai nom semana le brave gars vous
êtes né à bagdad et vous avez grandi
donc sous la dictature de saddam hussein
votre père médecins irakiens votre mère
il l'avait rencontré en algérie quand il
quand il faisait ses études
et puis il ya eu la guerre du golfe en
91 les bombardements vous avez raconté
l'abri la fuite en iran avant la france
et puis love story évidemment voilà
évidemment évidemment et sollers
philippe sollers qui dit elle a un
minois d'écrivain
philippe sollers dans tous les cas il
est mal tombée puisque publié chez mango
un livre qui s'appelle un jour j'ai
quitté bagdad sous titre est de bagdad
au loft avec une préface de malek boutih
qui est président de sos racisme
kenza mais là messieurs voilà donc avant
de parler du vivre on a parlé un petit
peu de la situation en irak alors les
inspecteurs de l'onu n'ont pas trouvé
d'armes de destruction massive à
l'époque ils ont dit qu'ils n'avaient
pas et les américains n'ont pas trouvé
non plus manon a priori on en parle très
peu ces dernières semaines donc je suis
très très étonné et très en colère parce
que c'est quand même la première cause
pour laquelle bush est allé quand même
en irak est ce que vous avez des
nouvelles de votre oncle j'ai essayé de
trois fois mais après avoir un bombardé
un centre de télécommunications un lait
très difficile de contacter sa famille
les délais belle de votre père non plus
non plus et en jordanie là non il est
loin il est loin ouais page 53 du
bouquin vous dit papa si tu savais comme
tu me manques
oui c'est vrai il manque beaucoup c'est
vrai qu'à ce côté où mon père malgré
tout ce qui m'a infligé ça reste quand
même mon père j'ai énormément de respect
à son égard ouais mais pourquoi ne prend
pas contact qu'est ce que vous lui avez
fait je n'ai rien fait a priori j'ai
sali le nom de la famille c'est vrai que
c'est quelqu'un aussi qui a évolué dans
une mentalité très oriental donc avec
beaucoup de tabous beaucoup de principes
direct pour lui une fille enfin en tout
cas sa propre fille qui réussit antennes
et enfin qu'ils essayent de réussir en
télé est pour lui une fille légère et
pas respectable et quelqu'un qui en tout
cas c'est moins la famille mais bon je
ne vais rien fait dans l'oeuvre banon
j'ai même pas couché babou des finances
et des bas mais non c'était pas moins
avec la c est quoi avec
j'ai eu un partage sous la couette il
était gentil vraiment c'est vraiment
violer leur miracle maintenant non oui
je me prépare la première - ouais j'ai
envie d'y aller en libye et la whey
pollution s'accrochèrent de chimie
grandes baies vitrées collection
initiale je me prépare surtout les aider
humainement mais vraiment parce que j'en
ai très envie et pourquoi pas le fait
que je mettrais irakien et l'arabe peut
en tout cas idées beaucoup
d'associations humanitaires fait mobile
à part et mobiles à la mairie des
applaudissements
et puisqu'on en marche tout cela vous
dit au revoir quand ils me serrer dans
ses bras
je sentais comme une obligation
furtivement rempli sur jamais senti
vraiment un
un vrai une vraie tendresse non je crois
que le seul moment où j'ai vraiment
ressenti de la tendresse et de
l'attention de sa part ça a été le
moment où je vais vraiment menti j'ai eu
un gros mensonge à son à son égard ou je
lui ai dit qu'un jour j'étais à l'école
et que saddam était venu nous rendre
visite à l'école et qui m'avait fait
sauter sur ses genoux il avait promis de
recevoir son compère en tout cas dans
son palais pour lui offrir un poste
beaucoup plus important à l'époque et
moi bien sûr comme je savais qu'il avait
une adoration une admiration assez
grande pour ce dirigeant à l'époque je
me suis dit la seule manière pour moi en
tant que petit ou bien qu'on aille vers
en fait c'est l'homme qui voulait
conquérir votre père bien sûr oui
session les espaces ont toutes les
petits suis le premier rhum de leur dire
c'est toujours leur père alors au moment
de la guerre du golfe d'un seul coup il
ya les bombardements vous voyez votre
père qui perd complètement les pédales
et là d'un seul coup le mythe s'effondre
parce que c'est votre mère qui prend les
choses en main je crois qu'il ya eu une
panique générale ou là ma mère est
devenue mon père et mon père devenu ma
mère c'était assez grande héros oui ça
change c'est le mérite
trois quatre cinq ans arrache de c'est
vrai oui le mérou change de sexe a
beaucoup dany michaud de ces escargots
le monde la mode à la mode elle est
ce sera dans mon coin tier one man petit
extrait vient ensuite c'est la fuite en
iran l'arrivée en france la zone la
galère dont de votre mère vous dit
qu'elle n'a pas dormi une seule fois
dans un lit normale en disant on voit la
difficulté de cette arrivée en france
et puis les premiers jobs les premières
sorties vos débuts à la radio les débuts
de votre vie amoureuse aussi kenza parce
que je crois qu'il faut en parler ou des
rires et puis votre premier chagrin
d'amour
comme toutes les jeunes filles voilà
mais là c'est assez dur parce que vous
un jour vous le voyez qui se pavanent au
bras d'une fille 1 et la fille vous vous
avez un mot pour elle vous dites que
c'est sa [ __ ] ofia bah oui on réagit
surtout tous tout comme ça on est
attaché à quelqu'un qu'on aime et c'est
vrai que une semaine avant une disait
que j'étais l'homme de la femme de sa
vie par les épines design semaines avant
que j'étais la femme de sa vie
et là vous voyez avec moi et si bon bah
deux semaines après je le vois se
pavaner avec une nana c'est sûr que ça
me fout en l'air la bouche intervient il
balance je manquais les américains de
temps entoure toujours quand il faut
vous diriez ça vous
vous verriez votre jus avec une se
pavanait qu'une [ __ ] a même ne sait
même pas sa salade à huawei donc il l'a
donc après ce chagrin d'amour kenza vous
décidez de jouer là la séductrice
williams - elle décide c'est comment
sans les grands ateliers et j'ai
souffert
j'espère maintenant c'est moi qui vais
manipuler les mecs sains
donc je vais être un petit peu la
dompteuse demain c'est à dire que cet
hymne chanteuse au plus
le café de bienvenue est donc là l'ami
de 18 la grosse [ __ ] à desdunes la
capsule apollo ya des règles la fille
décide de vraiment devenir une âme et
vous savez de quoi je parle quand même
voix basse et sait rien on collectionne
avec harbaoui pour montrer qu'on s'en
fout quoi non pas du tout mais gros
devant la situation
voilà chantal inviter quelqu'un de
chantal
c'est la caméra historique
je me suis calmé vous être tombé dans le
piège de l'amour et vous dites dans le
bouquin pour mon plus grand délice à non
c'est vrai mais qui est l'heureuse élue
heureuse et plusieurs interviews de lui
c'est un garçon formidable
il fait quoi dans la ville et enfermés
dans un appartement le mourre irak bien
dire le rivage
oui c'est mary paye as oui j'ai le
peuple me répétant très bien merci
je veux voir les abîmes l'année ça gagne
est que dit oui rivages de quoi tu y
fera bien ce fait la mésopotamie c'est
entre les deux fleuves parce que mary où
céline potamot c'est entre le tigre et
l'euphrate il bras n y encore des
services plus qu'avant l'hypothalamus un
resto c'est bien connu c'est le rythme
bien donc
et puis voilà et puis arrive le leur
arrivée dont vous dites donc intéressant
vous dites kenza magnifique et
douloureuse aventure
oui c'est vrai c'est un mélange de
moments de bonheur et le moment de
douleur surtout parce que parce que
d'abord c'était ça oui regardez oui
c'est vrai moi c'est dans le secret des
moments très pesant parlement ayant des
besoins vous tourniez métier comme un
animal en cage oui on était comme des
animaux qui tournoient en 15 ans qui
tourne bien merde à tourner au maire de
pars donc au minimum de vous tourner et
j'ai envie de trouver les bons oui oui
oui c'est vrai qu'à force de s'ennuyer
malgré ce que les gens ont vu ils ont vu
surtout des gens qui étaient tout le
temps en train de s'amuser tout en train
de s'éclater
alors qu'on avait des discussions très
sérieuses dans l'oeuf quelquefois
politique sociale ce qu'on a rarement
montrées donc ça fait de nous à déjouer
donc l'achat ne montrez pas qu'on
parlait de shock and awe pire que la
chaîne coupé ça on avait des discussions
comme comme un groupe qui se sait
villeroché pour la fission nucléaire
pendant deux heures s'est jamais passé
mais jamais on a vu que les en culotte
dans l'adoration et la manipulation voie
malgré tout craindre à sion nous parce
que le soir de la sortie du loft c'est
quand même pour vous l'apothéose vous
êtes en direct sur fun radio avec mac os
[ __ ] pense à ça que magnifique
vous êtes-vous dit comme une petite
princesse de dans un conte de fées et
puis voilà et puis après voilà après ça
retombe pour les sollicitations ce fonds
sont plus rares le téléphone cesse de
sonner tout le temps - de couverture à
collectionner pour votre maman on peut
après ça redescend doucement comme ça
oui on fait y avait pas que ça mais
c'est vrai que ma mère prenait un
plaisir à collectionner à la russie ont
ainsi les rangs mais comme toutes les
mamans passent quelques valeurs si dans
les magazines sur et c'est quelque chose
de très de très mignon quoi mr mais
c'est vrai que six mois après le loft
après la fin du loft on s'est rendu
compte que tout notre notoriété en tout
cas été basée que sur des ide et c'est
vrai qu'il ya une vraie recherche
d'identité
ce fait et on se demande réellement qui
on est et où va alors revenir dans la
vie de tous les jours
c'était difficile avec la le phénomène
révolutionnaire que tu as accès à fait
au niveau dire au niveau de la télé je
veux dire on a donc c'est vrai qu'il ya
un moment où on est au bon duo bout du
gouffre et on se demande qu'est ce qu'on
fait vous pensez quoi du parcours des
lofteurs loana par exemple j'ai pas j'ai
pas à portée du jugement parce que déjà
deux mois ça a été très difficile lors
de la passe compenser quoique son
parcours fait son petit bout de chemin
voilà mais je passais pas une c'est pas
une grande cantine
tulle aime pas il y avait des lofteurs
tulasne pas elle non puis c'est le
stress est très bien pu rider marine est
l'uriné
dans la seconde elle nous détestent
laure de lattre
tu sais pas c'est quoi la vie est là dit
elle a dit qu'elle nous a écrit un livre
parce qu'on parle plus d'elle ouais
quand on dit en prenant elle vomit du
bleu du vert
peut-être mais bon je vais pas jouer son
jeu en lui disant que quand on se crée
les ailes sur m6 fallait peut-être
commencer sur les carrières et sur quoi
et on dirait moi avec choisi elle aussi
que sa voix si le site casser les autres
alors qu on sort tous les to les toutes
les deux finalement du même moule
alors dans télé 7 jours il ya eu le top
50 des stars de la télé réalité
eh oui chantal j'avais raté mes
histoires de cinéma précédente est prêt
à l'entrée puis le temps bio télé 7
jours chantal alors numéro un toujours
loana steevy 4e qu'est ce qui s'est
passé la chute et bah non c'est m
mais qui et deux lors votre amie laure
de lattre 5e pas mal assise dessus de la
couette 10e et vous en dire c'est a
dégoûté quand elle avait même pas lu
j'ai même pas lu l'article je sais même
pas vraiment vraiment et puis c'est pas
du tout ce qui m'intéresse vraiment quoi
et je veux dire c'est vrai que je
m'intéresse à leur carrière à travers
les médias je regarde un petit peu ce
qu'ils sont devenus
et je pense que c'est la même chose pour
eux mais c'est vrai que je me
franchement je me permets vraiment pas
du g et puis je leur souhaite vraiment
bon courage parce que ça doit pas être
facile pour tout le monde voilà c'est
sûr mais dans les boîtes de nuit parce
qu'ils sont tout le temps dans les
boîtes sont les voitures on votera oui
mais bon quand on passe de son temps
dans les boîtes de nuit ça veut dire
qu'on travaille pas
les échos la divison ils ont éliminé
parce que vous étiez trop arriviste trop
grande gueule ils ont dit non c'est
parce que je disait tout haut ce que
tout le monde pensait tout bas c'est la
bonne l'utiliser tout ce que dit moi
sérieusement sérieusement imaginer
imagine en étant 91e à la guerre du
golfe
vous restez à bagdad vous seriez devenu
quoi je pense que je serai pas la femme
que je suis aujourd'hui je crois que je
serais peut-être mariée de force avec
quatre un gamin avec un mec que mon père
me représenter voilà mes et puis pas
avec ce physique
voilà messieurs riez ouais ouais ouais
vraiment vraiment à quoi sert vraiment
vous seriez quoi j'ai passé et puis vous
imaginez encore plus encore le togo le
mot